in two ways the service that print media
traditionally makes available is editing
which can turn almost almost
unintelligible random words into
intelligible language depending on how
good a writer you're dealing with the
vast majority of mankind today writes
badly and finds it difficult to may have
good ideas but finds it difficult to
write more than articulate sentence I'm
really judging by my students each year
my students say yeah which is a good
university we get very good students are
less and less able to express themselves
in writing so the print media more than
ever provides editing and provides
authority respectability if I go to a
newsstand thirty years ago and there are
five newspapers it's important for me to
know that I trust this newspaper and I
don't trust that one but if today I go
to the web and there are thirty thousand
sites it's even more important for me to
go to a site which I have some reason to
trust consistently over the long term I
think the print media have failed to
make the most of and their opportunity
they know they may well disappear
because they're approaching things in
the wrong way but but editing to produce
coherent readable text and authority so
that readers know how to spend no matter
how much information there is I ask the
same number of minutes in my day
and and I need to look to sources I
trust beginning with the print media
newspapers I read magazines I read
publishers I trust to give me advice as
to how to spend those minutes Crenn
media will flourish if it does that
don't know that it will